Ever wondered about the deepest desire of SCP-082,
the smiling, compulsive liar
cannibal known as Fernand?
Foundation researchers snapped a photo of Fernand
while he was sharing a meal with SCP-4820,
using SCP-978, The Desire
Camera, and this was the result:
"SCP-082 performing at the Paris Opera
House, as it appears in the 1986 musical,
The Phantom of the Opera. Based on the
costumes and sets visible in the photograph,
SCP-082 seems to be portraying Méphistophélès
in Charles Gounod's opera adaption of Faust
while SCP-4820 portrays the title character.
Several audience members are visible; identified
individuals include Peter Dinklage, Batman (as
depicted in early issues of Detective Comics),
SCP-507, Lon Cheney Jr. (as the Wolf-Man), and
Maximilien Robespierre. All visible audience
members have apparently been moved
to tears by SCP-082's performance."